- [Voiceover] Why are some couples happy,
and some are straight up miserable?
- I will stop acting like your mom
when you stop acting like a child.
- What, are you on your period?
(upbeat music)
(symphony music)
- One way to understand
how relationships work
is the concept of Attachment Theory.
Attachment Theory is the idea
that the way that your
parents treated you as a baby
affects you in your romantic
relationships as an adult.
(crunch)
Mmm. Apple-y.
(smack)
There are three types of adult attachment:
secure, anxious, and avoidant.
- A securely attached person
has healthy relationships.
They are confident that
their needs will be met
by their partner and
they can depend on them.
- All right, I attempted
to make a latte for you.
- Aww thank you. I saved
you the calendar section.
- Where's my latte?
- Who are you?
- How'd you get in our house?
(whoosh)
- An anxious person has a fear
of rejection and abandonment,
so they're always worried
that their partner will leave them.
- So where are you going?
Are you mad at me?
- I'm going to the bathroom.
- Oh, okay, I love you.
Uh, don't you wanna say someth-
- Uh, I love you too.
- Thank you. Text me.
- A person with an
avoidant attachment style
feels uncomfortable with intimacy.
(soft violin music)
When they get close to another person,
they tend to panic and pull away.
- Hey, I wanna tell you something.
- M-hm?
- I love you.
- It's late, I have to go,
and wash my friend's bird.
- What are you talking about?
- Later, ha ha, see you around!
- I just said I love you!
(soft violin music)
- No, no, don't even, please don't.
(whoosh)
- According to a study done in the 1980s,
56 percent of people are secure,
19 percent are anxious,
and 25 percent are avoidant.
What can you do if you're
an anxious or an avoidant?
One way you can improve your relationships
is by learning more.
Talk to a therapist,
read books and articles
about attachment theory,
educate yourself,
- Also, two insecure attachers
do not work well with one another.
- Hi, I'm a classic avoidant.
- Hi, textbook anxious. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
By the way, as soon as we fall in love,
I will panic and immediately run away.
- Oh, that's perfect
because as soon as you start
to run away I'm gonna get super clingy,
like do you have a Facebook, an Instagram,
I'm gonna stalk everything.
- You sound like a disaster.
- I am.
- I'm gonna disappear, it'll
be like I never existed.
- Oh, that's gonna devastate me.
- I'm so turned on right now.
- Same.
(whoosh)
- If you're an anxious or an avoidant,
try being in a relationship
with a secure person.
Being with a secure person
can calm your neuroses
and put you at ease.
- I'm gonna use the bathroom,
I'll be right back.
- Oh you don't have to
tell me where you're going.
Look, I am completely secure now, okay?
So you can go to the bathroom,
you can flirt with other women,
I mean, you could text your ex,
I mean, we wanna have
an open relationship,
we could talk about that, I don't care.
- I don't wanna do any of that.
- Oh good, thank God, I
don't wanna that either.
- Whatever your attachment style is,
you are worthy of love,
and can still have
successful relationships.
So just be aware of your patterns,
and make positive choices.
Also, I've been drinkin'
margaritas since 10 a.m.
so I'm feelin' pretty positive.
(slurp)
It's gonna be a good summer.
(smack)
I can feel it.
(mellow music)
(whooshing)
(squeaking)